several moderate House Democrats are
joining the call to impeach President
Trump House Speaker Nancy Pelosi will
meet with key committee chairs this
afternoon before her entire Democratic
caucus discusses the whistleblower
complaint Nancy Cordes is on Capitol
Hill Nancy on impeachment are we now at
a turning point it does seem like the
dam is breaking on the Democratic side
Tony just last night ten Democrats most
of them from swing districts the kind of
Democrats who have been most cautious
about impeachment all announced that if
the new allegations are true that they
would then be open to impeachment
proceedings seven of those Democrats
signed an op-ed saying that if the
president used taxpayer dollars as
leverage for his own gain that would be
a threat to all we have sworn to protect
the authors are all Democrats who
flipped Republican held seats last year
and House Speaker Nancy Pelosi has made
it clear time and time again that she's
going to stick with them because they
are key to keeping the house in 2020 so
if we see more of those frontline
Democrats as they're known join their
ranks than Pelosi is surely not going to
be far behind
we know she's already been burning up
the phone's to measure support but she
has also said repeatedly that Republican
support would be key to an impeachment
effort and so far Tony most Republicans
are either standing by the president or
staying silent Nancy thank you as we
mentioned the president is scheduled to
speak at the UN that's around 10:15 a.m.
Eastern time 9:15 a.m. Central and we
will bring it to you in a CBS News
special report